-Performing "Runner"
from his upcoming album,
"God Save the Animals,"
please welcome Alex G!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I like people
who I can open up to ♪
♪ Who don't judge
for what I say ♪
♪ But judge me for what I do ♪
♪ And when I think of
people I look up to ♪
♪ My runner, my runner, my man ♪
♪ I laugh when you say
the wrong thing ♪
♪ Mouthing off to
everybody else but me ♪
♪ They hit you with
the rolled up magazine ♪
♪ My runner, my runner, my man ♪
♪ Load it up, know your trigger
like the back of my hand ♪
♪♪
♪ What's a couple grand
rolled up in your pocket? ♪
♪ I won't tell nobody, baby,
you don't tell nobody ♪
♪ Yes, I have done
a couple bad things ♪
a couple, yeah, yeahhh ♪
-♪ Know your trigger
like the back of my hand ♪
♪ Load it up, know your trigger
like the back of my ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]